from an MCU adventure to a live-action
adaptation of a children's cartoon these
movies avoided our ratings by ditching
scenes that were overly gory too
explicit or simply in poor taste there
are only a few big DC Heroes that you
can easily imagine in an R-rated feature
but Batman is definitely among them he's
a gritty character who operates in a
dreary City fighting underworld
criminals but all his movies even the
Christopher Nolan ones have always been
PG-13 or Tamer when director Zack Snyder
paired The Dark Knight with the man of
steel and Batman v Superman dawn of
Justice though it wanted to go darker
than ever before if Snyder had gotten
his way Batman v Superman would have
been even more mature tell me
thank you
dear plead it's not even spoken before
about extended versions of certain
scenes in the movie that would have
earned it in our rating he revealed to
collider that there were some violent
moments that had to be trimmed like the
opening the director clarified the
opening of the movie The North African
sequence is really much different these
deleted moments weren't seen in theaters
but they did show up in the ultimate cut
of the film which was released on
Blu-ray and DVD speaking to
Entertainment Weekly star Ben Affleck
said he was completely in favor of the
more violent version being made
available saying why not have an R-rated
version that you release for downloader
on DVD later I think that's smart
said during a while to post graduation
party Kant Hardly Wait follows a group
of teens as they look for love sex and
revenge with some edgy late 90s gags and
a PG-13 rating it's not quite a sex
comedy but it's also not exactly family
friendly either way it was almost rated
R and there was plenty left on The
Cutting Room floor after the studio made
the last minute decision to help it get
a wider audience act does Seth Green
told vulture in 2015 there was like 40
minutes of that movie that was cut out
the movie was originally an R-rated
movie Sony in the midst of putting it
out it was at the very beginning of the
re-emergence of the team comedy was
scared everyone was really kind of
concerned about what it was going to be
according to the actor CGI was used to
delete a beerbong in one scene while a
sequence involving weed brownies had to
be removed some deleted scenes may even
help explain other odd moments in the
PG-13 version of the movie Green
continued Jason segall's got a
watermelon that is filled with vodka and
kept in his freezer for all of senior
year and then he brings it out to
celebrate everybody goes for it on the
ground so that's why he's eating
watermelon for the rest of the movie
it's one thing with an R-rated sex
comedy is cut down to get a softer
rating like can't hardly wait it's much
more rare though for a film that's
designed to be a family comedy one based
on an iconic children's cartoon no less
to contain R-rated moments that had to
be pulled if writer James Gunn and actor
Sarah Michelle Geller are to be believed
though that's exactly what happened with
the 2002 live-action adaptation of
Scooby-Doo according to Gunn the movie
was originally slapped with an R rating
by the MPAA and plenty of changes had to
be made one scene that was deleted
depicted a soul swapped Daphne and Velma
locking lips as Geller confirmed on
Watch What Happens live there was an
actual kiss between Daphne and Velma
that got cut I feel like the world wants
to see it I don't know where it is
that's not all as Gala tells it there
was also a scene removed that raised
questions over Fred's sexuality she
elaborated there's always been an
implication about Fred being interested
in both parties it all got cut he
planned this somehow didn't he hey good
looking when Jim Carrey came to famous
in the mid 90s it was for a string of
vulgar comedies that included the mask
and Ace Ventura Pet Detective though
they were all rated PG-13 they pushed
the envelope as far as they could with
jokes that stretched the boundaries of
good taste for the 1994 fairly Brothers
classic Dumb and Dumber one seamless
film that pushed the movies in
appropriateness levels way over the edge
watching it back now it's pretty easy to
understand why it was made much shorter
the moment comes at a truck stop when
Harry and Lloyd stopped to refuel their
vehicle and stretch their legs Lloyd
goes to use the men's room and spots a
little bit of graffiti scrolled in the
store that promises some manly love at 2
15 am noticing it's exactly 2 15 at that
moment Lloyd turns around to find sea
bass entering the men's room the scene
made it into the movie's Final Cut but
what didn't are some of the violent
statements that the trucker makes
towards Lloyd the rest of the film may
have been full of gross out gags and
over-the-top vulgarity but this explicit
threat of sexual assaults and murder
would have no doubt pushed the picture
into R-rated territory
Steven Spielberg's Jaws might not be
classified as a horror movie by today's
standards but it nearly had some spine
tingling scares that had audiences in
1975 jumping out of their seats despite
being centered around the bloodthirsty
shark that's menacing a Coastal
Community it might surprise younger film
fans who haven't yet seen it that the
film was actually rated PG and contains
very little actual Bloodshed most of the
deaths are off screen and the shark
itself isn't even seen clearly very
often in many ways it's a lack of Gore
that contributes to the film's scare
Factor but if the movie had been
released as originally intended it would
have included at least one graphic
moment likely warranting in our rating
in the movie Chief Brody's son Michael
and his friends out sailing when their
boat is overturned by the shark coming
to their aid is a man in a paddle boat
bertima would have been the most
jaw-dropping moment in the movie The
Shark emerges out of nowhere and devours
the man dragging him under as he clings
to a screaming child in a behind the
scenes featurette actor Ted Grossman who
played the victim admitted it was just
so violent so horrendous that they
couldn't use it Spielberg agreed saying
that it was too bloody and that the
scene was in bad taste I'm not gonna
waste my time arguing with a man who's
lining up to be a hot lunch I'm going to
see you later Indiana Jones and the
Temple of Doom is famously one of the
films that prompted the creation of the
PG-13 rating as some parents were
outraged at some of the violence in the
PG rated flick during test screenings
the action-packed pre-core sees the
whip-wielding radical in India facing
off against the Demonic Cults that
engages in human sacrifice the most
infamous scene involves a cult leader
tearing the still beating heart out of a
man's chest and holding it Aloft the
Final Cut is pretty violent but it was
almost even worse a number of scenes
were removed from the film presumably so
it could avoid an R rating one depicted
a thuggy torturer who's seen brutalizing
a group of slave children before he
himself is burned by lava in Grizzly
fashion reporting on the Uproar
surrounding the film The New York Times
revealed that sensors in the United
Kingdom were horrified that Indiana
Jones and the Temple of Doomer managed
to get a PG rating in the states
journalist Al Jin hametz wrote James
Furman Secretary of the British board
said that Indiana Jones as it stands
could not even receive the more
restrictive 15 rating which prohibits
children under age 15 from seeing the
film to get a 15 rating he said a scene
depicting the slow burning to death of a
man who was an absolute agony must be
trimmed in 2022 Black Adam was supposed
to change the hierarchy of power in the
DC extended Universe for the arrival of
Dwayne Johnson as a titular anti-hero
instead the movie bombed at the box
office and James Gunn and Peter
saffron's DC reboot was announced soon
after unlike guns are rated redo of The
Suicide Squad from the year prior though
Black Adam had some scenes removed and
altered to tone down the blood and gore
Heroes don't kill people
[Music]
well I do according to producer Hiram
Garcia Black Adam was originally rated R
and some scenes had to be axed in order
to get the PG-13 rating the studio
wanted he told collider we really wanted
to make sure that we honored the
character of Black Adam one of the
things he's known for is his aggression
and violence and to do a Black Adam
movie that didn't have that just
wouldn't have been authentic so we
always went into this knowing that we
were going to push it as far as we did
the only deleted scene that has come to
light so far was discussed by VFX artist
Nicos calasides and Greg Teagarden in an
interview with befores and afters they
described a moment where Black Adam
violently tears an arm from a mercenary
Soldier and its spasms after hitting the
ground Tea Garden joked you can't have a
disembodied hand lying on the ground on
the finger just all of a sudden
twitching it's rare that the Star Trek
franchise goes too far with its content
but in the series second big screen
housing the creators almost went
overboard with one particular scene the
film that remains the most beloved in
the franchise Star Trek 2 the Wrath of
Khan saw Ricardo montalban's genetically
augmented super Tyrant returned from
Exile and seek revenge on Captain Kirk
there was an entire character removed
from a key subplot that involved Khan's
quest for vengeance though the villain's
child a toddler was originally supposed
to pop up at the climax of the film when
Khan detonates the Genesis device in a
last-ditch effort to kill Kirk in a
deleted scene the device sucks a kid
into its Vortex before destroying the
entire ship the full scene has never
surfaced but images from the sequence
were published in Star Blazer magazine
in 1982. with the horrific death of an
infant at the center of this major scene
it's not hard to see why the whole thing
was scrapped when one conjures up an
image of an R-rated Marvel movie Thor
probably isn't the hero that Springs to
mind however according to ragda
Christian Bale who played the villainous
Gore the god butcher in Thor love and
thunder there are actually a series of
deleted scenes that would have made the
Thunder gods for solo alsync and R-rated
Affair regarding his collaboration with
director Taiko waititi Bale told inverse
with Thor love and Thunder Tiger and me
we kind of knew that some of the stuff
we were doing probably wouldn't end up
in the film but we wanted to just push
it and see so what happened despite
their wish to push the boundaries of
what could appear in an MCU movie both
Bale and waititi eventually agreed that
the scenes a shot weren't right Bale
continued ultimately it is and should be
a film that all the family can go and
enjoy and Chris Hemsworth a couple of
times he looked at me it was like dude
that's a little too far I don't think
anyone's gonna want to see that unless
it's an R-rated film you really have to
stop being like this
all the acts when you called the dentist
despite those moments not making it to
theaters Bale says he has no regrets
since he had a great time filming
regardless
based on a series of young adult novels
the Divergent films follow Tris Pryor a
defiant young woman in a dark future
where people are segregated based on
their virtues when she joins a dauntless
faction due to her bravery she realizes
that she is different from the rest and
she must keep her unique nature as
secret as the world teaches on the brink
of War squarely aimed at Twins and teens
the first movie in the franchise had to
cut some moments that were deemed too
harsh for the PG-13 rating the studio
was aiming for despite being directly
adapted from a sequence in the book it
was decided that the scene in Divergence
in which dauntless rookie Edward is
stabbed in the eye was simply too brutal
to show though it did find its way until
the deleted scenes portion of the home
video release its removal from the
actual film clearly disappointed actor
Ben Lam who considered his characters
brutal disfigurement a highlight of the
production lamb told collider the scene
that I really enjoyed the most was the
eye stabbing it's very gruesome
according to director Neil Berger the
ice stabbing scene was actually removed
to fix the flow of the movie rather than
to help it get a G13 rating